GUEST SPEAKER: Now good morning,
Navajo Environmental Agency
members.
Given the proposed
revitalization
of the nuclear power
industry and the hints
that uranium mining might be
revitalized in the region,
there's a growing concern
amongst the agency members
regarding what this means
for us, especially given
the controversy of historical
precedence happened
in this area in the 1960s.
I'm here today to explain,
amongst the various measures
that we are implementing, why
local knowledge should be given
serious consideration
and why the,
and why we should
actually be involving
the local members of community
in the process of developments
of uranium mining.
Now firstly, the involvement
of local knowledge
improves and enriches
the scientific process.
Problem framing is an
inherently subjective process,
and it's not something that
science can't solve on its own.
When we look at, what
exactly are the problems,
who are the people who are
exactly going to be affected,
and what do they think about it?
These are questions that don't
lie in science, but rather
in the people.
And that's why we must
move away from thinking
about a positivist
view of science,
that science holds all the
answers, and involve the people
and what they think about it.
And secondly, we understand
from many stories in history
that science is
inherently uncertain.
There are uncertainties
involved in quantifying effects
of various measures.
There are uncertainties
involved in determining
what impacts that a particular
activity, in this case, uranium
mining, will have on
the future generations.
And therefore, look and one
brings in an important element
that science is not able to.
And this is ultimately patterns
and trends in time and space
that people live
in the area have
been observing over decades
and over a large area.
Ultimately, if you
bring in scientists
to examine their environmental
impact of uranium mining, what
will be captured
often tends to be
a screen shot, a
shot in time of what
actually is going to happen.
Whereas these people have
had the benefits of decades
of experience, and
they will be able
tell us what's most likely to
happen over time and space.
And lastly, democratization--
The uranium mining activities
that are being taken
do not involve only the
scientists or only the industry
members but also the people.
And it's important to ensure
that their views are being
heard and are being
taken into account
in the scientific process.
Of course, there will be
opposition to such views.
Firstly, people might
say that in the past,
the reason for these problem
were that proper rules
and regulations were ignored,
and the adverse impacts were
actually minimal.
I would argue that the
reason why proper rules
and regulations were ignored is
the fact that these people were
not actually involved in the
development of these rules
and regulations.
And also, there is
a false dichotomy
between scientific knowledge
and local knowledge that
actually, where people
think that scientists
are the only ones
that are qualified
to come up with good science.
Whereas people who have not
been trained in this area
would not be able to do so.
Studies have shown in history
that a lot of this view
actually stems from
the fact that people
aren't used to the language
and the technical terms used
in science.
But when that
barrier is crossed,
that people, given
their critical thinking
skills and their
reasoning skills,
are equally able as
trained scientists
to be able to contribute
to the discussion.
So ultimately, how should we
ensure that local knowledge is
taken seriously?
How should we incorporate this?
This involves a mindset shift.
Local knowledge does not seek
to supplant scientific knowledge
but rather strengthen it.
We need to move away
from this false dichotomy
and allow locals and
scientists to sit at the table
as equals, not because they
are equally good at something,
but because they bring different
things to the table that
are of equal value.
We also would like to recommend
that boundary workers be
searched for and
hired to actually take
part in this process-- "boundary
workers" meaning people that
are not only able to
communicate with those
on the scientific
side of the boundary
but also with the local
side of the boundary.
These might be
people, locals who
have been trained
in science and who
not only understand the
scientific culture but also
the local culture.
At the same time, people,
just because something
is local knowledge does
not mean that it is right.
So in that sense,
high standards have
to be expected of the
presentation and gathering
of local knowledge, not in
terms of the use of very
formal technical language, but
in terms of critical thinking
and reasoning.
And only when these scientific
standard, these high standards
are enforced on
our local knowledge
will they be taken
seriously by the scientists.
And ultimately,
this entire process
is as much a cultural process
is it is a scientific process.
It's not just about the
scientific methods that we use,
but also in terms of leveraging
the cultural and social
elements inherent
in the community.
For example, we might look
at the social hierarchy
in different regions.
And this varies, actually,
from community to community,
from town to town.
Is there a central
figure of trust that we
can bring into the discussion?
Do we have to forge
unity between both locals
and the scientists?
And are there certain
social practices
that might need to be
avoided or adhered to
in terms of working, or getting
locals and scientists to work
together?
So ultimately, our
agency's role is
to avoid the events that
happened in the 1960s.
And I believe that
one way of doing that
is to actually bring
in local knowledge.
Not as a form of opposition
to what the scientists have
been doing, but as enhancement
to their work, to enrich it
and to ensure that whatever
solution is worked out
is in the best interest of both
the community and the industry.
Thank you.